quel est l'état d'esprit des
participants à cette marche écoutez un
mirror on arrive bientôt 1 à la fin de
cette marche blanche
on est à deux pas de la tour eiffel avec
ses proches ces familles ces
manifestants et qui ont participé
aujourd'hui à cette marche blanche pour
rendre hommage à cédric bosch ou via
pour demander justice et vérité après
qu'il ait perdu la vie en suite à une
interpellation policière il ya un enfant
le jour pour jour alors cédric ajouté on
le rappelle il a été il a fait l'objet
d'une clé d'étranglement lors de cette
interpellation qui a provoqué donc une
fracture du larynx il est décédé deux
jours après et j'ai tout fait ce sont
les derniers mots qu'il a prononcés
avant de mourir donc voilà ce que
réclame aujourd'hui les manifestants et
c'est la justice
pour cédric joue bien alors parmi les
manifestants aujourd'hui figurent
plusieurs personnalités politiques dont
figurent eric coquerel qui est député de
la france en sont mises elles dites nous
pourquoi est-ce que vous avez tenus vous
en tant que député a participé à cette
marche blanche aujourd'hui pour trois
raisons la première c'est en hommage à
cédric souvient et pour demander justice
je vous rappelle que cédric julia c'est
pratiquement la même affaire que floyd
aux etats-unis c'est-à-dire quelqu'un
qui
est assassiné par la police qui dit j'ai
tout fait qu'on les cons et qu'on laisse
pour les secourir
or constatez vous même ça n'a pas fait
autant de bruxelles en france vous êtes
à prévenir des seuls médias disent
présents jeudi alors que c'est ça fait
un an jour pour jour qu'a eu lieu c'est
à cette affaire la deuxième chose c'est
pour nous dire qu'il y à des violences
policières on le voit bien ces derniers
temps qui sont anormales et il faut
demander justice toi qu'on prenne effet
et puis enfin on sait que c'est la re
mobilisation contre la loi sécurité
globale qui contient plusieurs articles
problématique cet article d'interdiction
de filmer
si elles payent des images pour cédric
souvient au n'en sera rien ne serait
rien ce qui s'est passé mais aussi deux
articles totalement liberticide
quand on est qu'elle nous opposons et là
c'est le sait on va dire que c'est une
première journée de remobilisation la la
la famille notamment le père de cédric
dénonce un mépris de la part du
gouvernement
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire écoutez
quand le père de cédric me décrivait
tout à l'heure la situation des trois
policiers notamment du policier qui a
été le j'allais dire le plus agressif
c'est quand même à croire qu'il ait pas
été suspendu enfin je veux dire on voit
ça dans un an
aucun autre métier quand il ya des
défaites tellement évident donc je
comprends sa colère et son inquiétude
par rapport à cette situation c'est
tellement évident que il ya longtemps
sur l'espace et bien merci beaucoup avec
eric coquerel le jeu rappelle député de
la france ont soumis ce qui est bien a
jugé nécessaire pour lui en tant que
député de participer à cette marche
blanche pour rendre hommage donc à ce
livreur de 42 ans qui a perdu la vie il
ya un an jour pour jour après des suites
d'une interpellation policière
nadège à merci pour toutes ces
précisions